in a few moments where she's in that
will stand up in front of that stop the
boats Podium he will walk out in in
front of it in Downing Street because
stopping the boat's one of his top five
uh political priorities but it has been
immensely complicated so let's sort
through what we learned today and what
we still don't really know so the
legislation that Zoella brevmond has
published today does one big thing and
that says that forever or forevermore if
you come over if you are caught coming
over to the United Kingdom on a small
boat you will never again be allowed to
apply for asylum in the UK that will be
it we will uh we will take a record of
your identity and you will be barred
from any route back into the UK and from
ever coming to settle in uh in this
country and here he is to explain his
plan
my policy is very simple
it is this country and your government
who should decide who comes here and not
criminal gangs
now the first step is understanding the
nature and scale of what we are dealing
with
the number of people entering the UK
illegally in small boats has more than
quadrupled in just the last two years
those illegally crossing the channel
are not directly fleeing a war-torn
country or persecution or an imminent
threat to life
they have traveled through safe European
countries
they are paying people Smugglers huge
sums to make this dangerous
and sometimes tragic Journey
now the reason that criminal gangs
continue to bring small boats over here
is because they know that our system can
be exploited that once here illegal
migrants can make a multitude of Asylum
modern slavery and spurious human rights
claims to frustrate their removal
and the risk remains that those
individuals just disappear into the
black economy
now that is the reality we must deal
with
and with a hundred million people
displaced around the world if we do not
deal with it now the situation will just
get worse and worse
people must know that if they come here
illegally it will result in their
detention and Swift removal
once this happens and they know it will
happen they will not come and the boats
will stop
that is why today we are introducing
legislation to make clear that if you
come here illegally you can't claim
Asylum you can't benefit from our modern
slavery protections you can't make
spurious human rights claims and you
can't stay
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
either to their own country if it is
safe to do so
or to a safe Third Country like Rwanda
and once you are removed you will be
banned as you are in America and
Australia from ever re-entering our
country
this is how we will break the business
model of the people Smugglers
and this is how we will take back
control of our borders
now this bill provides the legal
framework needed to deliver this in a
way that no other legislation has done
before
this is tough
but it is necessary and it is fair
and this legislation will be
retrospective if you come on a small
boat today the measures in this bill
will apply to you
and this is just part of what we are
doing I've always been clear that this
is a complex problem that can't be
solved overnight and will require us to
use every tool at our disposal
that is why I've already secured the
largest ever small boats deal with
France and patrols on French beaches are
already up 40 percent
I also promise progress on enforcement
and we've increased raids on illegal
working by 50 percent
I've also negotiated a new deal with
Albania which accounted for a third of
all small boats arrivals and that's
already delivering we've returned 500
illegal migrants to Albania and we are
seeing far fewer come as a result
this shows that there is nothing
inevitable about illegal migration
deterrence works and with Will and
determination the government can get on
top of it and we will
now this will always be a compassionate
and generous country
it is something that we're all rightly
proud of
just look at how we've welcomed
ukrainians and syrians from refugee
camps that embraced Hong kongers fleeing
the Chinese clamp down
but the current situation
is neither moral nor sustainable it
cannot go on
it's completely unfair on the British
people who have opened their homes to
genuine refugees but are now having to
spend nearly six million pounds a day to
put up illegal migrants in hotels
it's unfair on the people who come to
this country legally to see others
skipping the queue
and it's devastatingly unfair on those
who most need our help but can't get it
as our Asylum system is being
overwhelmed by those traveling illegally
across the channel
if we can't stop the boats our ability
to help genuine refugees in future will
be constrained
full control of our borders will allow
us to decide who to help and to provide
safe and legal routes for those most in
need
now I understand there will be debate
about the toughness of these measures
all I can say is we have tried it every
other way and it has not worked so I say
again
my policy is very simple
it is this country and your government
who should decide who comes here not
criminal gangs and I will do whatever is
necessary to achieve that
thank you
it will take some questions from the
media if we could start with
the BBC
thank you prime minister Chris Mason BBC
News if by the time of the next German
election you haven't stopped the boats
will you have failed
thanks Chris
so look I I wouldn't be standing here if
I didn't think that I could deliver on
this promise at the beginning year I
stood up in front of the British people
made five promises and one of them was
to stop the boats and since I've had
this job I spent a lot of time thinking
long and hard about how to solve this
problem and I'm confident that the bill
we're introducing today will help us do
that it will mean that for the first
time we will have a system whereby if
people come here illegally they won't be
able to stay they'll be detained and
they'll be swiftly removed and as we
deliver on that people will see that
there is no point in coming here we will
have that deterrence effect but I've
also been clear throughout that this is
a complicated problem right there is no
one silver bullet and the legislation of
course it's really important and that's
why today is important but it's just one
of the many things we're doing we need
to cooperate with our allies
particularly the French which is why the
deal that the Home Secretary and I
worked on at the end of last year is so
important and we hope to continue
deepening and strengthening our
cooperation with the French and other
European allies it's why the deal we
announced with Albania is so important
and I think it's just pause on that for
a second Albania accounted for over
around a third of our illegal migrants
last year but because of the steps that
we've put in place the New Deal that
we've announced what we're seeing now is
that we're returning hundreds of people
back to Albania and we're seeing the
numbers come down considerably so that
shows to me that if we get this right it
will make a difference
now we're in the early stages of it but
we've given it long hard thought and you
know I said at the beginning of the year
that you know I I only promise what I
believe I can deliver and I will
absolutely deliver on what I promise and
that's what we're going to do today
yeah but all of these things play their
part is that no one thing is the answer
to this question right and that is the
point the legislation is absolutely
critical there is no way to stop the
boats without this legislation but
there's legislation on its own won't do
it that's why we need all the other
things that I've talked about as well
all of those things will help us achieve
that goal of stopping the birds but as I
said I you know I promise I promise what
I can deliver and I will deliver what I
promise and that's what we said we would
do that's what we will do
right next I've got ITV
um prime minister you talked about the
importance of Swift removal uh more than
two-thirds of Asylum Seekers don't come
from Albania how is it compatible with
the British traditions of humanity and
compassion that you are criminalizing
incarcerating potentially uh forcing
statelessness homelessness destitution
on Asylum Seekers many of whom are as
you accept vulnerable and traumatized
before you have in place agreements with
third countries to which you could move
in a swift way your words uh those
Asylum Seekers
this this is a country that has always
been open welcoming compassionate and
generous to those in need just in the
last few years since 2015 we've welcomed
almost half a million people to this
country half a million from Ukraine from
Syria from Afghanistan from Hong Kong
that's our record that's our compassion
and everyone should be incredibly proud
of that I am but what is not
compassionate
is to allow the current situation to
persist there is nothing compassionate
about allowing vulnerable people
to perish in the channel we had a stark
reminder of that just a few weeks ago
off the coast of Italy when over 50
people died including children
right people being exploited by criminal
gangs and Smugglers I was just at Dover
earlier today talking to the teams that
have to deal with this on the ground as
the Home Secretary and the immigration
Minister see almost every week There's
Nothing compassionate about that
situation persisting and there's nothing
compassionate or fair about us not being
able to help the truly most vulnerable
people around the world because our
system is being overwhelmed by those who
are jumping the queue and coming here
illegally and they are not the most
vulnerable they are traveling through
multiple safe European countries they
are paying people thousands of pounds to
get here so look I want to move to a
system where we break that cycle
we deter people from coming here
illegally jumping the queue and actually
we as a country can then make sure that
we decide who we come who we bring here
how many and make sure that we target
that compassion that generosity and
support on the world's truly vulnerable
people and that's why the legislation
that we're announcing today not only
does the things that we need it to do to
break the cycle and give us the powers
we need to send people
back but it also allows Parliament to
set a quota on how many people we would
welcome here under safe and legal routes
as we've done so brilliantly in the last
few years I think that's the type of
system that would come on Broad support
right and I think that's not just the
right thing to do I think is actually
the moral and compassionate thing to do
because the current system is broken and
it's not fair on anybody and the sooner
we can put an end to it and focus our
support on those who most need it I
think the better off everyone will be
but if you can't expel them yet why do
you think the small boats will stop
well the legislation is a necessary step
on being able to return people either to
their own country where it's safe to do
so or to a safe alternative like Rwanda
and I'd say we already are returning
people you mentioned Albania Albania
accounted for a third of all illegal
migrants last year because of the the
deal that we struck and the new
procedures we put in place we are now
returning hundreds of people back to
Albania and that's right and that's the
right thing to do and we need to focus
our resources focus our generosity and
compassion on the world's truly most
vulnerable people that's what I want to
do I think that's what the voice of the
country wants to do too at the moment
that's not possible because we're being
overwhelmed with people who are jumping
the cube breaking the laws and that's
not right and that's what we're going to
change
next sky
thank you prime minister five years ago
the then Home Secretary Sajid Javid said
he was going to make this route on
viable since then we know we've seen
tens of thousands of people in the last
five years where do you think your
predecessors went wrong why are you
different and can I also ask what does
success look like to you will you be
setting targets for where you want the
numbers to be in a year's time
so this is look not about dwelling on
the past because the situation has just
got far worse as I said in my remarks
earlier just in the last two years you
talked about when Sergeant was Home
Secretary so just in the last two years
the numbers of people crossing the
channel legally have more than
quadrupled right that is the scale of
what is happening and their forecast to
get worse and the other thing is not
just us right so anyone who thinks this
is just a UK specific problem isn't
being straight with you this is
happening across Europe right Europe
last year saw something like 63 increase
in the numbers of illegal migrants one
of the highest numbers they've
experienced in almost a decade and
that's because globally this is a
challenge and it's only going to get
worse unless we do something novel that
we do something bold to try and stop it
and that's what our legislation today
does now you know successes are stopping
the boats success is us having a system
that people come here illegally are
returned back to their own country where
it's safe or an alternative and if we
can get that working as I'm confident
that we will be able to as we already
are with Albania we will see the numbers
come down because people will see that
it is not worth their while to risk
their lives to pay gangs thousands of
pounds for something that ends up not
what they expect and and that is the
system that we're going to deliver now
we've always said as I've said to the
questions earlier there's no one Silver
Bullet to this right so not only do we
need the legislation to be implemented
and make sure that that we can Implement
that as quickly as possible we also need
to cooperate with our allies we need to
make sure that we keep signing returns
agreements we need to step up what we're
doing on immigration enforcement as we
are and raids are increasing
dramatically so those are all the
different things that we need to do and
we're going to do all of them we're
firing on all cylinders to grip this
problem and people can judge us on our
results we've only been in this job a
few months we're already making I think
more progress than we've made in a long
time and as a result of this legislation
I think we now have something that is
very powerful we haven't done anything
like this before and it gives us the
tool that we need to implement the
system that I described and we've gone
further than anyone's gone before it's
right that we're doing that because the
situation has got far worse than it was
just two years ago but we're responding
appropriately we're responding tough
with tough measures but they are
responsible they are proportionate and
crucially they're fair but you're not
setting specific Targets in terms of the
numbers well I think you look people
will judge us on our results and as I
said we're already seeing the results
illegal migration rates up 50 since we
announced the proposals to do that with
uh Robert at the end of last year
already hundreds of people being
returned to Albania we're getting the
Asylum backlogged down as well down by 6
000 just in the last couple of months
since we've improved all the processes
there you deal with the French at the
end of last year hopefully further
cooperation to come we promise new
legislation I'm standing here today with
the Home Secretary introducing it so we
are we are continuing to deliver the
things that we said and I'm highly
confident that as we keep moving forward
people will see a big difference on this
LBC
the ocean with LBC first year prime
minister you're meeting the French
President Emmanuel macron later this
week do you accept that in order to be
successful with this policy you are
going to need his fulsome cooperation
what are you prepared to offer him in
return and if I may just very briefly on
Sue grave do you still have faith in the
Integrity of her report into partygate
on on Sue gray as as you know that the
cabinet office is reviewing the
circumstances of her departure I'm not
going to preempt I'm not going to
preempt Their fines so I'm not going to
comment further on on that situation
with regard to the French you know as
you heard me say before there's no one
Silver Bullet to solving this problem
it's a it is a complex problem and we
need to use all the levers all the tools
at our disposal and a crucial one of
those is cooperating with not just the
friends but also with our other European
allies so I was really pleased after I
became prime minister having spoken to
President macron we managed to get the
Calais group up and running as well the
Home Secretary attended that that's
fantastic because that's not just France
that's other northern European countries
coming together to discuss this issue
the share challenge that we all face and
how we can work together to solve it
right that that meeting happened and
actually there's some very tangible
things coming out of that about data
sharing and cooperation of iron
enforcement agencies which is great
specifically with the French we
announced a new deal the biggest deal
that we've had for more patrols on
beaches up 40 percent it's significant
and better cooperation and collaboration
between our teams again I've just got
back from Dover talking to them about
the benefit and the difference of that
collaboration works and I'm very
grateful actually I put a record my
thanks as the Home Secretary I know
she's been over there and spoken to them
herself I'm very grateful to the
cooperation and support and
collaboration of the French teams on the
ground they work very closely with our
teams and because of the work that they
do you know they help intercept around
about half of all the attempted
Crossings and that number varies and at
the moment it's on the way up which is
great news and that's part of the
conversation that we'll be having on
Friday is how can we strengthen and
deepen and broaden that cooperation but
this is ultimately a share Challenge and
actually you're seeing across Europe you
know France is looking at new laws to
tighten up their Asylum regime Germany
has appointed a special commissioner on
Asylum Italy is look looking at new laws
to to talk about how they regulate
search and rescue operations in the
Mediterranean because many countries are
facing this the same Challenge and
actually if we work together it's going
to be easier for us to to deal with it
particularly on Upstream cooperation of
our law enforcement agencies because the
best thing we can do is try and disrupt
the grounds you know right at the
beginning at Source before people end up
arriving here and that's the kind of
work that we can do more of and
hopefully we'll be having that
conversation on on Friday as well but
I'm very grateful to the teams in France
for the support and cooperation that
they have given us because it really it
does make a difference
right
who we got next uh GB news
Tom Harbor to GB news uh on the face of
the bill whom secretary says that she is
unable to make the statement that the
provisions of this bill are compatible
with the Human Rights Act which of
course Incorporated the echr into
domestic law already Legions of lawyers
are preparing to tackle you over this
legislation but firstly are you up for
the fight and secondly what's Plan B if
they win
um well look of course we're up for the
fight and we'll be standing here if uh
if we weren't but we're actually we're
confident that we will win and on the
section 19 1B statement I think it's
really important to for everyone to
recognize there's absolutely nothing
improper or unprecedented about pursuing
bills with a 19 1B statement it
absolutely does not mean that the bill
is unlawful we believe that it is lawful
that we are acting in compliance with
our International
obligations
and we are also meeting our obligations
to the British public to make sure that
we have control over their borders and
that it is them and their elected
representatives who are deciding who
comes here
um but with regard to section 19 1B as I
say entirely in line with precedent in
fact a previous labor government in 2003
uses section 191b statement as they were
passing a piece of legislation you know
we believe we are acting in compliance
with international law in compliance
with the echr and if challenged as you
maybe you may well be right and as we've
seen in these matters we do get
challenged
um you know we will fight that hard
because we believe that we're doing the
right thing and it is compliance with
our obligations but to be clear no plan
B I'd say we we are we we are confident
that we are acting in compliance with
our obligations and again I just point
out on the Rwanda policy which many
people said again uh was wrong and we
expected The Challenge on it as you saw
recently we were successful in defending
that policy I think actually
unequivocally successful in the high
court that policy is now moving to the
court of appeal in just over A month's
time so we'll await the outcome of that
but again we're confident in our
arguments we believe we're doing the
right thing and you know I believe the
courts will see that as well
right talk TV
prime minister in CH there you said you
will do whatever is necessary to ensure
that you can stop the boats to follow on
from that question does that include
leaving the echr if necessary to keep
your promise to the public and if I may
a huge part of this plan is detaining
people often for long periods of time
according to the legislation how many
detention centers are you planning to
build where will they be and how many
people will they house
so on the two questions we don't believe
it is necessary to leave the CHR we
believe that we're acting in compliance
with it and acting meeting our
International obligations but as I said
also meeting our obligations to the
British public to have control over our
borders and ensure that it's them and
their elected government who's into in
control of who is coming here
um I believe that we're acting entirely
rightly and and correctly in that regard
and I take those obligations seriously
as does the Home Secretary and that's
why we've worked long and hard to design
a piece of legislation that that is
tough that is novel that is ambitious
but that is in compliance with our
International obligations and I'm
confident that it will be effective and
with regard to attention I I'd say it
the idea is not to have to detain people
for prolonged periods of time and
actually what the bill does is
completely change how we process
people's claims to stop that from
happening because part of the problem
we've got at the moment is people can
frustrate the system because they can
make one claim and then down the line
they make another claim and then another
claim to give you a sense of it you know
that's almost there were more than 70 of
people that we detained pending a
removal then filed a modern slavery
claim right when we put people and told
them they were going to go to Rwanda
two-thirds of them claim modern slavery
you know towards the end of a process
and you know we can't have a system like
that which can be taken advantage of so
what this new piece of legislation today
says is that you've got to make your
claim right at the beginning any and all
claims that you have and we will hear it
quickly in fact there's very few that
will be valid under this uh new system
and we will process them in a matter of
days or weeks
um so it's not the idea that people are
kept here for indefinitely long periods
of time that's not what we want to see
and we want this system that is working
far quicker than what we have today so
that we can swiftly remove people we do
have thousands of detention places
already and we're in the process of
building over a thousand more in two
different sites and we will do
everything that we need to make sure
that the bill
is delivered and that work has already
started you know but we're very
confident in what it does but Grizzly is
not about detaining people here for
months on end it's about processing them
very quickly which the bill will enable
us to do and then removing them you know
that's the system we want to move to
times
prime minister um the Home Secretary
today described the echr's interim
injunctions on Rwanda fights as opaque
and deeply flawed she said that they are
undermining our ability to control our
borders do you agree do you think the
echr overstep the mark and are you
prepared to take action around that
secondly Simon case is facing a lot of
criticism over his WhatsApp messages
which have been linked to the telegraph
over Matt Hancock one of them accused
you of being bunkers will Simon case
still be your cabinet secretary by the
time of the next election
um thank you thank you Steve on on
um rule 39 I should have actually
addressed that in the previous question
yes you know the home sector is
absolutely right and in the sense that
these were all 39 orders are opaque and
they don't meet I think what anyone
would describe as a kind of natural
Justice test and that's because they're
conducted behind closed doors you don't
know the name of the person who's
sending these things down and we have
absolutely no right to apply for the
case to be dismissed we have no right to
appeal those things aren't formalized as
I said they're just kind of handed down
by these unnamed Duty judges and it
feels like at Five Minutes to Midnight
right so that process does seem not
appropriate and what we want to do is
see reform to that process the attorney
general has already had an informal
conversation with the court in
Strasbourg about that I think we believe
that other countries you know share some
of the the questions and observations
that we've had about how that process
works I think everyone can get behind
the idea that yes of course there should
be a court that has due process but that
process needs to be fair and if we think
that something's being handed down we
should have the right to have the right
to know who's doing it and to challenge
it and appeal it that's just as I said
it's a matter of natural justice so we
will start the process of engaging with
Strasbourg to try and get reform to rule
39 and look at our track record on this
is is good actually and some time ago we
embarked on a similar reform process
with the court particularly on rule 39
and it resulted in some changes which
are called the Brighton declaration I'm
not a legal expert so Venezuela can
probably fill you in on the detail
afterwards but so our track record on
this is good and you know our concern is
we you know we can't be subject to a
process that doesn't meet simple tests
of natural Justice and that's why we
want to try and uh get that process
reformed and I said I'm confident that
we'll be able to work with others uh to
do that
um and on Simon look I you know I
haven't read all these messages because
I've been busy working on this but what
I would say is a cabinet secretary has
done a great job uh actually helping
with today in particular like he works
very hard to support me he works very
hard to support the government's agenda
and particularly on the issue of
tackling illegal migration it's very
much a cross-government effort right and
the work that Robert swallow and I have
been doing over the past few months
involved lots of colleagues from across
government pulling together so that we
can grip and solve this problem the
cabinet secretary has been at the heart
of coordinating all that work I'm very
grateful to him for that and I look
forward to working with him
um for a very long time to come quite
frankly so hopefully that will answer
your question on that
and lastly we've got the eye
uh yes primary sit large thing from the
eye you've talked a lot about the
deterrent effect of these new laws but
how many thousands of Channel Asylum
Seekers do you need to deport before
people start getting deterred from
making those Crossings and are you
confident you have enough capacity in
Rwanda there's only a few hundred places
there and through returns agreements to
places like Albania to begin having that
deterrent effect quickly once the new
laws come in
misconception about the random thing it
is an uncapped scheme so everyone keeps
saying they've only got 200 places it's
an uncapped scheme so that's like
everyone should know that so they should
have confidence that that's um that's
what's happening there and having just
spoken to the Roland and president the
other night they remain committed to
their partnership with us and looking
forward to making sure that it can work
properly in the way that we all want it
to
um but I do think that the deterrent
effect can be quite powerful quite
quickly and I Love Actually one of MPS
in Parliament today Tim louton was
talking about a home Affairs select
committee trip that he'd been on to
France and actually where they were
talking to some of the people in France
who said that after the Rwanda deal was
first announced they suddenly saw a
change in Behavior about people who were
there uh who stopped them wanting to
come over here and were trying to figure
out about staying there and that was
just on the fact that they'd heard about
Rwanda when it was announced
um but but also just look at what's
happening in Albania right so we you
know we worked hard got a new agreement
with Albania towards the end of last
year you know I made the statement or it
was early early December and we've just
started operationalizing that new new
agreement the guidance we've changed to
our case workers here and again it's
early days so you know let's look
carried away but the the signs are very
promising right we have now returned
hundreds of people and Robert's been
working incredibly hard to to get people
back on planes so hundreds of people
have been returned uh we're also doing
comms in Albania and we are seeing a
change in the numbers coming here from
Albania and also how our system is
treating them when they are here and
making it clear that they shouldn't be
here and actually they should be refused
and sent back now you know that's only
been in place for a matter of weeks but
it does give me the confidence that the
deterrence can work and will work and
that's why this bill is so important and
that's probably a good note for us to
end on
um because that's what this rests on it
right it rests on the simple premise I
think the common sense straightforward
premise that if you come here illegally
you will not be able to stay you will be
detained and you will be swiftly removed
to your own country if it's safe for you
to be sent back there or indeed a safe
alternative like Rwanda and that system
delivered an operational will serve as a
strong deterrent it will break the cycle
of criminals and if you spend any time
with people at border force in Calais or
anyone who deals with these people be a
no doubt the people who are doing this
are criminals and people are dying and
being taken advantage of because of the
system that is now in place and it would
not be right to stand here as prime
minister and allow that to continue and
not try absolutely everything we can to
stop it from happening and that is what
we are doing right we have been working
long and hard at this and as I said it's
complicated it won't be solved overnight
but we will under termination and
creativity we will be able to grip this
problem and whether the bill is one part
the cooperation with France is another
part returns agreements enforcements we
are doing it all because when I said at
the beginning of the year that we would
stop the boat I meant it and we will
keep working until we've delivered that
thank you very much
there we are it's uh one minute past six
uh you're watching the NewsHour Rishi
sunak there uh holding a news conference
on the whole issue of small boats he
said our Asylum system can be exploited
by spurious human rights claims he said
we have to make clear that if you come
here illegally you cannot stay you will
be removed and banned from re-entering
the country forever he said the bill
provides the legal framework to do this
although some are already questioning
that he said this will always be a
compassionate government but the current
situation is neither moral or
sustainable let's talk to our Deputy
political agency Sam coats who was uh
listening to all that interesting Sam he
said um
I will absolutely deliver on what I
promise
um he promised to stop the small boat I
mean that's quite a Gamble
it is I mean he refused to put a number
on it therefore it implies that the
Target that Rishi sinak is today
announcing that he's heading for is zero
small boat crossing the channel by the
time of the next election that is
effectively what he is now on the hook
for with this package of changes uh and
this legislation that's been announced
today we have some certainty uh
Richardson like in that press conference
underlined the big change is that those
people who go across the channel in
small boats will face a permanent bar on
being able to re-enter the UK and ever
apply for any kind of citizenship
naturalization uh or registration as a
UK assistant citizen so that's the thing
that the legislation does and what it
also does is it gives the Home Secretary
of the day currently similar Brotherman
28 days to effectively Deport uh to
remove that individual from the United
Kingdom sending them either back to you
the kind country that they came from if
that is safe or to Rwanda if and when
those flights battery to rawanda can be
started so that's what we know and the
Prime Minister insists that he believes
that all of this can be done within the
European convention on human rights
although he thinks you need to change
the process of that uh suggesting that
British government embark on some
attempts to reform the Strasbourg Court
uh good luck unlike how Rishi sudak
suggested I think previous attempts by
Britain to reform that Court have
actually run into some difficulty but
Mark I think what was interesting about
that prob about that press conference we
didn't actually get very many answers
about the sort of practical side of how
this is going to work because when you
think about it
um there were last year something like
uh 45
000 uh people who came over in small
boats and now the home office it's an
Associated agencies have to effectively
get those people uh find those people
detain those people and remove them from
the UK within 28 days
practical terms is enormously difficult
not least for a government Department
that's not exactly got a track record of
being able to sort things out very
easily so when people come in they're
first of all got to work out whether
they're old enough to be detained
whether they're well enough to be
detained and removed and then the home
office has got to work out where is safe
to take them back to whether or not
there's an agreement to take those
people back to that country an agreement
with the country they want to return
them to and what's going on with the
Rwanda flights where the situation is
still a little bit opaque so a huge
amount of trust it seems to me in this
system is being placed in the home
office to deliver an extraordinary
amount of work in a short period of time
now whether or not this is a success
will all come down to officials into
Allah brahman's department and the
associated agencies border force and the
like all working at speed through other
really tricky issues like where do you
detain them what happens if people end
up being in detention for significantly
more than 28 days because taking them
back home more somewhere else proves to
be quite difficult or the whole
bureaucracy gets clogged up because
there are simply so many people coming
through there are lots of practical
problems that this government's likely
to face even before you get to the
potential legal difficulties and you
didn't hear a lot about that today uh
questions focusing really on principle
another big issue a principle that the
Prime Minister made clear was changing
is that there is in future going to be a
cap on Asylum claims and for the first
time there's going to be a numerical
ceiling on the number of people that
will be given that Asylum however uh
desperate it would seem the situation in
certain parts of the world that another
big change in principle uh this is a lot
for Richardson act to deliver he wants
to be seen as a pragmatic person who can
work through the detail in order to
deliver for the British people this is
the announcement this is in a sense only
the first hurdle we're gonna have to
watch over the coming months to see how
successful he is yeah I mean this could
be a legal fight that goes the distance
do you think that ultimately
Rishi Suna is prepared to walk away from
the European convention on human rights
so from all the how can we put it very
fudgy language that we're getting in the
government document my my best guess at
that answer Mark is actually no even
though quite a lot of people around him
would like to Rishi sunak is insisting
that the package of legislation that's
been outlined today is compatible with
European convention on human rights a
lot of people that disagree with that
think that it's going to be tested in
the Strasbourg Court which is your next
answer as I indicated a few minutes ago
is to try and reform the strasbord court
because he doesn't like the way that it
operates he says that it's opaque uh and
doesn't think that uh judgments are
handed down fairly and can be challenged
properly now none of that gets away from
the fact that if it is deemed to be
incompatible with human rights then
Richard sunac has a problem where he'll
have enlarged minority of his own back
benches and some in his own cabinet
wanting him to leave but bluntly the
kinds of deals on brexit he's just done
on Northern Ireland uh I think you can
expect an extremely angry response from
other EU countries if he now tries to
pull out of echr this is a sort of fight
that's going to be deferred really I
suspect until the next Manifesto ahead
of the next election with two camps on
the Tory side Pro and against trying to
uh get the prime minister to follow
their view I suspect he's just kicking
the can down the road on that one
because it's quite a a difficult issue
to get too far into the Weeds on the
difficult thing the thing I don't
understand Mark is whether or not Rwanda
flights will start again uh even if
Strasbourg continued to have doubts on
it there just seems to be such murky
language around that in critical parts
of government documents that that you
know that fundamental Cornerstone of
this plan that says it's not safe to or
we can't Deport you back to the country
that you came from then we'll take you
to Rwanda the legality around that seems
very complicated and I'm not quite sure
from anything that's been said at that
press conference said in the house or
from the government documents uh what's
going to happen with that right I know
you've got to go just very briefly
um Rishi sunak off to meet president
macron howl sign could that be
well I think it's significant for a
couple of reasons there'll be lots of
policy discussions tidying up on brexit
I suspect uh receiving that no doubt
promising to get through on the British
side the legislation that EU are
planning to ratify in the coming weeks
when it comes to the Northern Ireland
deal there'll also be policy discussions
around defend the UK and France uh
cooperate very closely on defense even
at times where the political uh
relationship perhaps macron and Boris
Johnson hasn't been uh so tight and
they'll also of course talk about the
stuff that we're discussing today the
issue of migration how much more can the
French do in order to help with patrols
across the channel to stop uh the small
base but the much bigger issue Mark is
just a sort of reset on the UK French
relationship I think the symbolism of
Friday when this Summits due to take
place in Paris will be one of two
countries that haven't had a very easy
relationship you know you just think
back to the leadership contest last
summer Liz truss unable to say uh
whether or not uh France was an ally or
not not now Richardson that pressing the
reset button looking to be seen to be
working much more collaboratively with
our EU Neighbors after effectively seven
years of successive Prime Ministers
starting with Theresa May effectively
beating up Europeans and particularly
beating up the French as part of those
brexit negotiations I I think Rishi
sinak is actually changing the direction
of diplomatic relations the way that the
UK handles diplomacy it began in Earnest
with that brexit deal uh gosh just a
week ago but that said a very different
tone from his predecessors and I think
he continues to try and Forge
relationships and build on consensus and
collaboration which bluntly just hasn't
been the British way of doing things
since 2016. okay Sam thank you very much
indeed so uh let's just recap where we
are with all this the government has
been defending its plans to clamp down
on Asylum Seekers reaching the UK on
small boats in the last half hour the
Prime Minister said that his plans to
detain and remove almost all those
making uh the channel Crossing in this
way are tough but he insisted that the
measures are necessary and fair but
Oxfam says Rishi sunak's new illegal
migration bill
will only create more cruelty and more
misery for migrants let's just take a
look then at the contents of the bill it
states that anyone arriving in the UK on
small boats will be banned from claiming
Asylum and can be detained without bail
within the first 28 days of Entry the
new bill
will also disqualify illegal entrance
from using modern slavery rules to block
deportation under 18s and those with
serious medical conditions will be able
to delay removal any other claims will
be heard remotely after removal an
annual cap determined by Parliament will
be introduced for the number of refugees
arriving by safe and legal routes here's
what the Prime Minister had to say at
that Downing Street news conference a
short time ago
people must know that if they come here
illegally it will result in their
detention and Swift removal
once this happens and they know it will
happen they will not come and the boats
will stop
that is why today we are introducing
legislation to make clear that if you
come here illegally you can't claim
Asylum you can't benefit from our modern
slavery protections you can't make
spurious human rights claims and you
can't stay
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
either to their own country if it is
safe to do so or to a safe Third Country
like Rwanda
and once you are removed you will be
banned as you are in America and
Australia from ever re-entering our
country
this is how we will break the business
model of the people Smugglers
and this is how we will take back
control of our borders
now this bill provides the legal
framework needed to deliver this in a
way that no other legislation has done
before
this is tough
but it is necessary and it is fair now I
understand there will debate about the
toughness of these measures
all I can say is
we have tried it every other way and it
has not worked so I say again my policy
is very simple
it is this country and your government
who should decide who comes here not
criminal gangs and I will do whatever is
necessary to achieve that
the Prime Minister there speaking in the
last hour let's go live to Dunkirk and
our Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
and uh well where you are Siobhan the
the problem they're trying to deal with
is pretty clear because these boats
continue to come
that's exactly right I've been to some
of the camps here in Dunkirk and down
the road in Calais today to talk to
people about this new bill and no one
had any idea that it was going through
when I explained to them the details you
if you get caught going on these boats
from today you could get deported you
could get blacklisted from the UK it
didn't really put people off to be
honest because many of those I've spoken
to feel that that's what they want to do
they say they're desperate and they
believe rightly or wrongly that their
best hope of a future that they want is
in the UK now the frustration for people
sitting in the UK is well that's not
fair on us they I can imagine people
shaking their fists at the television
saying well they're in France why can't
they stay there but that is the reality
of the problem that Rishi sinek and his
government have to deal with that there
are thousands of people who want to
cross the channel and when I spoke to
charity workers about whether they
thought this bill would make a
difference their concern was that
actually it could just make these
Crossings even more dangerous because
they feel that if there's a Crackdown
then the Smugglers will still want to
get their money so they'll still run the
boats but in a more dangerous way
they'll try and do it undercover people
will be snuck into the UK they'll be
more at risk of being exploited so
that's another problem that has to be
kept on the radar as well I think the
big question that everyone wants
answered is will this bill work if it
does come into force and that is simply
a question that cannot be answered here
right now because people just don't know
about it and I think that for it to be
effective that we'll have to see quite a
lot of disruption to those smuggling
gangs which will involve widespread
cooperation with France and other EU
countries as well because until the
Smugglers who are controlling these
routes are basically stop from being
able to do it effectively until a
message is given to people that if they
pay these Smugglers they might not get
across the channel that they're not
going anywhere then people will keep on
trying